Hello Michigan, I'm Conan O'Brien.
I was born in Brookline,
Massachusetts, but in my heart,
I've always been a Michigander.
What can I say?
I love my donuts from Dilla's,
and my beer from Bell's.
And because I love Michigan,
I'm urging all of you,
including the Yoopers, to
vote in the upcoming election.
Voting is a cornerstone of our democracy.
If you like democracy, but you don't vote,
You're not playing
Euchre with a full deck.
It's like saying I like Great Wolf Lodge,
but not family friendly water parks.
Or I like Vernors, but not ginger ale.
Or I like islands where
cars aren't allowed
and everyone sells fudge,
but I don't like Mackinaw.
It just doesn't make sense.
So get out and vote, 'cause
if you don't you're kind
of letting other states that
aren't as awesome as Michigan,
(whispers) Ohio.
Make decisions about your education,
your water, your roads, and your jobs.
Unlike Jim Harbaugh, voting costs nothing,
it's very effective, and
it lives up to the hype.
So whether you're in Detroit,
Grand Rapids, or way up
in Cheboygan, love the hot
dogs at Duke's, Cheboygan.
(howls)
It's important that you vote.
And as an honorary
Michigander, my vote is going
to the guy who'll fix
the potholes around here.
If you're not a registered voter
in Michigan, you've still got time.
Hope this face doesn't haunt your dreams.
See you at the Fleetwood Diner,
the one in East Lansing,
not the one in Ann Arbor.